was ist der Grund warum sich Ausländer
in Deutschland unwohl fühlen viele sagen
Deutsche sind unfreundlich das ist doch
so das ist einfach so zu den Ausländer
auch zu uns Deutschen
ich hatte auch eine Freundin die habe
ich auch so gesehen die sagt man in
Deutschland rein
gebracht so gesehen nein
nein sie konnte kein Deutsch und ich
habe ihr Deutsch beigebracht sehr schön
hinter euch steht gerade kein Pflaume
nee mein Schatz
wo man schon anreißen und andere Grenze
wird dann gefragt ja herzlich willkommen
also bleiben Sie hier und die wird oft
gefragt wie lange bleibst du will wann
fährst du wieder nach Hause
[Musik]
hallöchen haben Sie Zeit für uns eine
Sekunde würden sie bleiben wenn ich
Fachkraft wäre guten Abend haben sie
eine Sekunde Zeit für uns nein warum
nicht ich finde aber ihre Arbeit sehr
gut das freut mich danke aber ein
Gespräch der mir lieber Deutschland soll
attraktiver werden warum braucht man
dafür ein Gesetz warum reicht nicht
deutsche Freundlichkeit einer dieser
Grundtugenden eingeben aber unsere
Gesetze reichen nicht um das zu
vermitteln oh okay ja ich habe einen
schönen Satz entdeckt wir werden auf
Grundlage eines transparenten
unbürokratischen Punktesystems eine
chancenkarte zur Arbeitsplatzsuche
einführen kann man komplizierter
erklären dass es einfacher werden soll
also es geht ja darum dass wir
Fachkräfte brauchen in jedem Bereich
egal
wir müssen Thema Fachkräfte lösen aber
das kriegen wir nicht durch ungesteuerte
Migrationen was ist eine gesteuerte
Migration ja das heißt dass wir
sozusagen hier
Quatsch das alles Quatsch sondern wir
brauchen da komplette offener deswegen
freue ich mich auch über das nette
Interview alles Gute Ciao ich habe
Freunde gut qualifiziert die haben einen
deutschen ursprünglich deutschen und
fremdklingenden Doppelnamen und wenn die
sich um eine Mietwohnung bewerben und
nur den deutschen Namen nehmen bekommen
die mehr Einladungen sich die Wohnung
anzuschauen als mit dem anderen wir
haben unverändert da ein Problem wir
glauben wir sind sehr liberal aber wir
müssen noch an uns arbeiten
ich habe in Duisburg eine Wohnung
gefunden aber das ist ein anderes Thema
das schafft man ohne Probleme ja von wo
kam sie aus dem Urwald nee ich meine
jetzt okay es gibt viele Fachkräfte aus
dem Ausland die sagen
es fällt ihnen schwer deutsche Menschen
kennenzulernen ja also oft läuft man
sich einfach nicht hat man nicht die
gleichen die Deutschen sind tagsüber
draußen die Araber nachts ist natürlich
schwierig dann sie sehen nicht aus das
sind sie hier geboren ich würde gerne
ihr Freund werden
ich würde auch gerne ihr Freund werden
es kann so einfach sein zum Beispiel
sagen wir mal ausländische fachkräftig
stehe jetzt hier die würden sie mich
jetzt ansprechen okay na gut
Alter was machst du hier hallo
Kontakt aufzubauen naja dann würde ich
sagen erstmal ein Bier trinken und
schauen was man machen können oder ich
trinke nur Cola aber dann machen wir
Cola ist doch kein Thema und dann denke
ich können wir ein bisschen reden wie es
Dir geht wo du herkommst was für
Qualifikationen bringst ich glaube wir
haben für alle Bereiche hier
Möglichkeiten und da kann man sich ja
einiges finden
ja vielen Dank das war ein ganz normales
Gespräch aus der Kneipe alles Gute
thing in Germany
have the salad
[Applaus]
hallo Youtube unten könnt ihr den Kanal
abonnieren er deutet nach unten in die
Infobox neben mir gibt es weitere
interessante Videos Verlinkungen Komma
vielen Dank
[Musik]